there comes a sad time in every laptops
life where its memory fades and it's
hard drive slows and there's only one
place for it to go you lived a long
fruitful life
- those Windows Vista years we had so
many great memories together
wait you're not dead how are you running
so well okay that's not quite how things
happened but this week I pulled out some
of my old laptops and got them working
so well again that I'd actually use them
I turn them into Chrome OS laptops using
never wears free cloud-ready software
installing the operating system can be a
bit of a project but once you're through
you'll have saved some money and learn
something you'll need for things to get
started a laptop with an internet
connection a USB flash drive with a
minimum of eight gigabytes of storage
some spare time and a snack everything
else you need including detailed
instructions is at Neverwhere comm slash
free download the whole process took me
about an hour
download the OS install it on a USB
Drive and eat a snack while you wait
then plug the USB Drive into the old
laptop and reboot to the cloud ready
drive you can run Chrome on your laptop
just like that but if you decide to
install the operating system on your
laptops own internal drive be sure to
backup your files first some laptops
even let you dual boot cloud-ready works
best on computers 10 years or younger I
tested it on five different laptops and
was amazed at how well most of them
worked again the operating system is
simple to use and the hardware like the
trackpad and keyboard shortcuts just
work this Acer took one minute and 20
seconds to boot up with Windows 7 now it
takes 30 seconds when it came to web
browser performance this Acer was 2.5
times faster this 10 year old MacBook
and this ThinkPad were 20% faster sadly
this Intel Atom based Toshiba netbook
wasn't any faster there are some
downsides though getting Netflix to work
requires some extra steps there's no
technical support and chrome updates are
behind installing other Linux operating
systems like Ubuntu can have similar
results though may not be as easy to use
but what about Windows Windows tends
reduce system requirements allow it to
work on older systems but not
necessarily that well while my old
ThinkPad works great with Windows 10
I saw a frustrating amount of this on
the Acer I think you know what you need
to do next go grab that old dusty laptop
and bring it back to life with cloud
ready if it doesn't work what are you
really losing anyway so I guess I should
apologize